Zootopia a gleaming city where animals
of all breeds predator and prey alike
live together in peace and harmony CPD's
first rabbit officer Judy Hopps better
place bad news in this city gripped by
fear
this is Priority One pubs parking duty
sir I'm not just some token bunny
you should try cow you resign then they
should have gotten a real cop to solve
it you are under arrest for what hurting
a feelings you are a key witness no he
is Hey
I need you to run a plate all right I
know a guy you need something done he's
on it they're all
we are in a really big hurry I am on its
break I have 36 hours that we can only
solve it together it's not about how bad
you want something it's about what you
are capable I am a real cop never let
him see that they get here you bunny is
so emotional
maybe love but deep down we're still
animal for sure we're a naturalist Club
life's a little bit messy we all make
mistakes no matter what type of animal
you are change starts with you we gotta
go this cars the most feared crime boss
mr. beat
baby daddy is